Desde ovenega y mosfacer,
1 oposición rigurosa y constructiva en positivo,
1 objetivo muy claro,
nos hicimos trabajar desde oparlamento
para mejorar a vida de las personas,
para impulsar
grandes debates de país y sobre todo
vendo cale a mayor opción siempre
para darle 1 mayor vida os galegos y as galegas.
Y mosh VA a hacer, por lo tanto, 1 oposición a favor,
focalizada en los problemas realistas,
gente eh procurando
impulsar a las grandes transformaciones que necesita
este país. Usaremos sanosa fuerza para defender
todo a kilo
o que nos comprometemos a sanidad de pública.
1 encino libre de recortes,
1 belleza tranquila para las personas mayores
o oportunidades
presente moza
y de Cara a ese objetivo,
pues nos contamos con grupo parlamentario renovado
que combina experiencia con nuevas incorporaciones,
25 diputados e diputadas
que darán voz a todos esos galegos y galegas que
o pasado desde hoy todo febrero,
querían 1 alternativa diferente